what I'm really trying to get people to
understand how unbelievably real it is
to actually do something you like versus
actually doing something you don't like
I woke up this morning pumped because I
knew we were gonna have hardcore
operational meetings I just know that
from 1982 to 1998 I woke up every
September 12th Monday morning devastated
because it was the beginning of a very
long seven eight months of school
something I hated and now I watch people
do that every day for the rest of their
lives from 22 to 70 50 years of hating
it I only had to endure it for 16 years
people are doing things they hate for
the rest of their lives it's
unacceptable and when you DM me and
email me with your stories sometimes
people come with real stuff they're like
you don't get it I'm 19. both my parents
died in a car accident last year I'm
taking care of my seven and
five-year-old sibling gets real hard for
me to be like you have to follow your
passion that I understand yeah comma I
still tell that person with deep empathy
and compassion and kind and care of like
hey for now yeah always bet on optimism